the p47 had a massive air intake just
underneath the engine big enough for a
man to fit in the air from this intake
was not immediately funneled into the
engine instead it was routed to the back
of the plane first where it split into
two ducks one flowed into the
supercharger impeller which compressed
the air and returned it to the engine
carburetor while the secondary duct
flowed into an intercooler to cool the
air from the compressor section which
had heated up as a result of the
compressor ression of course this
compressor section needed to be powered
this was done through hot energized
exhaust which was collected from the
engine through this collection ring in a
separate duct system this air was
funneled to a lower turbine section of
the supercharger before the hot exhaust
was vented to Atmosphere
here